bang bang
what's up lunch money time tuesday
tuesday
not two day but tuesday while while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
in the right dress code paulina
marinova pompliano for those of you that
don't know
pelena's actual full name now is polina
evilova marinova pompliano which means
her initials are
p-i-m-p pimp what up
don't forget lunch money is sponsored by
block fi go
get money get paid you can go and you
can buy crypto on the crypto exchange
you can deposit crypto get a us dollar
loan or use my favorite product as an
investor
and a user which is you can deposit
crypto or stablecoin and earn up to 8.6
interest absolute no-brainer i just did
the intro
and the ad in less than 45
actually 55 seconds go click the link in
the description let's get into the heat
today
all right the heat is in europe at the
moment
after almost five days of fraught
discussions european leaders have agreed
to create a 750 billion euro
recovery fund to rebuild eu economies
ravaged by the coronavirus crisis
but it also agreed on a new eu budget of
nearly 1.1
trillion euros for 2021 through
2027 creating combined spending power of
over
almost two trillion dollars everybody
getting a bailout
everybody they just handing cash out you
want cash you get some you want cash you
get something you want some
they're going if you're a european
citizen they'll give you some too they
are literally
going to try to print their way out
whether it's the u.s
the uk in asia anywhere
central bankers are confused they
believe that you can print your way out
of a problem
you can't you simply kick the can down
the road and you as the individual
person
are getting taxed without even knowing
it you know how they say when the u.s
sneezes the whole world catches a cold
so what happens when
the u.s has covet i don't know what that
means
but what i do know is every time you
hear that they're gonna print money
all you need to think in your head is
inflation's coming
and when you hear inflation's coming
remember they're stealing
my wealth they're stealing money from me
they're stealing my purchasing power so
yes do they need to help people
of course do they need to print
trillions of dollars
i don't think so but what they're going
to do is they're going to steal money
from people
and the bottom 50 are going to get poor
the rich are going to get richer
and the world's going to keep spinning
and the world that we live in an
inflationary system is going to keep
doing exactly what it is designed to do
people keep us in our classes yeah
okay it's the most class warfare thing
that happens in society
inflationist yes they look literally
just so everyone is
super clear on this what they are doing
is in the united states i know the
number is better
so in the u.s right now the current
administration is yelling and screaming
about all the tax breaks that they gave
to people right corporate tax breaks all
this stuff
they're saying we did we drop taxes we
drop taxes we dropped taxes
but what they did was remember even
though they are getting
record levels of uh tax income they also
have been printing
so much money the fed's balance sheet
has expanded by three trillion dollars
this year 75
and so what ends up happening is you pay
for it
they just don't take it out of your bank
account in a traditional tax
system right where they take the dollars
away they just make your dollars worth
less
and so they're literally taking away
your purchasing power and so whether
they actually
tax you directly or through this
invisible tax of inflation
they are taxing you they're taking money
from the people to enrich the wealthy
one day our grandchildren are gonna
watch this and be like hey grandpa tell
us about inflation in 2020 and you'll go
on your rant again and you'll be all
proud
no you know what i'll say that bitcoin i
just gave you
your boy was looking out for you before
you even born that's what i'm going to
say what's going on
okay and when hey a little kid when you
watch this you're going to know i was
looking out for i was thinking about you
okay and group um the parent company of
alipay
which was founded by billionaire alibaba
billionaire jack ma is planning a 200
billion ipo it could be the largest
public offering in
history you wrote about this this
morning because i read your newsletter
what did you say
i don't think that jack ma founded it
what
facts i think alipay was founded by
somebody else and then the
chinese government forced them to sell
it to jack ma now jack ma owns alipay
but i don't think that actually jack
moff founded alipay
but we don't know um what i will say
though
is jack ma founded alipay uh again i
don't
uh if i wish it by alibaba group and
it's founder jack ma maybe
okay go on maybe he does maybe i got it
wrong uh but long story short
is uh ant financial owns alipay ali pays
got 900 plus million users across
uh pretty much all of asia and uh they
got grand ambitions
i literally think that this could be one
of the most valuable companies in the
world if
if big if big if they're able to do what
they want to do
which is essentially they want to go
from a consumer-facing company
where they are giving all the technology
directly to the individual
they're going to rip out piece by piece
that technology stack and try to turn it
into enterprise grade uh
products amazon has done this over the
last 15 years
uh obviously uh one of if not the most
valuable company in the world
and so alipay's got big ambitions do you
remember i remember writing about this i
think last year but it was considering
an ipo like a listing in new york but it
chose to bypass it in favor of hong kong
and shanghai
so are you upset about that no i'm just
curious like what does that mean did the
us
lose out on one of the biggest public
offerings in history
yeah but you have to well first of all
they're dual listing shanghai and hong
kong right
and right now there's incredible
geopolitical risk like they're literally
everyone forgets because of covid and
all stuff we were just talking about uh
de-listing all the chinese stocks off
the u.s stock market
like that that was a conversation
literally months ago
and so if that's the conversation you're
a chinese company why the hell would you
want to listen to the us if that's a
potential risk
and then on top of that uh there is a
big question
around will countries even allow alipay
to participate
right like why am i gonna let my
citizens uh transact on a platform that
has geopolitical risk to it
okay google maps what's up bang bang so
don't look i want to quiz you
so uber as you may know uses google maps
instead of apple
maps because apple is obviously inferior
to google maps they set it in their ipo
uber set it
apple maps is horrendous right so uber
though
has to pay google a certain amount to
use their google maps product for their
platform
it just inked another four-year
agreement
but how much do you think uber paid
google
for using maps during 2016 to 2018
a minimum of a hundred million dollars a
year no
how much god 58 million 58 million
that's a lot of money 10 to 15 million
dollars a year
it's a lot of what do you use their
stupid product well i just think of
uh i guess it's just a licensing deal
because if you're using like google
cloud or amazon aws for a company like
uber it would easily be hundreds
hundreds of millions
but it says i think it's if i'm correct
it says google maps
on your uber when you open the uber yeah
so there's licensing okay
that makes more sense so the 58 million
dollars over four years from 16 to 2020.
no 2016 to 2018. for two years it's 58
million okay so they're paying just over
25 million bucks is that how much the
new deal is
the new deal is unclear okay so well
it's a public company so we're gonna
have to say it
at some point yeah it'll probably be
something i'm assuming in the similar
uh range or higher because uber is
bigger now yeah um yeah i mean like
google maps is great
uh if you're going to go with a mapping
service i don't know who else you would
go with
so it makes sense to me sorry apple that
sucks for them make your products
yeah it's just and again part of it is
apple has tried to do a lot of it in a
proprietary manner but like
it's just very clear that it's an
inferior product not
in design or experience right just the
accuracy of the map and the direction
so by the way i think apple's product
will improve over time they just need
more data more time on the market
google's had an advantage
right fine okay what's up with the mock
esu is it monk
or is it marsh like machine no it's mock
how do you know
because that's how it's pronounced okay
like mach one
do you know what mach 1 is gryphon do
you know what mach 1 is
no okay what's up with the mock e so
looking to explore how far can push the
limits of electric vehicle performance
ford has created a version of its
mustang mash
e with seven electric motors that can
produce
a total of up to 14 1 400 horsepower
that's that's what it looks like so
first of all
i don't think this looks like an suv
yeah what are they calling it
second of all it looks ugly
third of all it's fast and it's electric
so it's cool
but calling this an suv is pretty much a
stretch it looks more like a station
wagon to me like a souped up modern
station
a race car yeah but i don't think that's
an suv
but here is here's an interesting fact
for a lot of people
most people actually don't know this but
racing is one of the best ways to get
better car performance so what i mean by
that is um
they will push the limits of technology
and they will push the limits of uh
innovation in the racing sector so
a lot of what ford and gm and all these
companies
figure out for their uh retail cars is
actually figured out on the racetrack
if you look in the electric vehicle
space there is actually a formula e
um a buddy of mine uh planet and i have
gone
uh he's a racer in formula e it's just
like formula one open
wheel around a track the whole nine
yards but the cars are electric rather
than gas powered
and the reason why they set up formula e
is because
they wanted to push the innovation and
push the pace of technology
for electric vehicles and they've done a
great job of that
the same guy is also the ceo of
something called
robo race if he's watching this right
now he's going to start cracking up that
i'm promoting this but
robo race is an autonomous race uh
league which literally they put uh i
think it's eight laps
four laps or with a human driver behind
the wheel
and then four laps or the car drives
autonomously by itself
and so they're building out this entire
experience just like a formula one or
formula e
then uh they're called theirs robo-race
and they're literally gonna build out
this to push the pace of innovation and
technology around autonomous vehicles as
well
so highly suggest go check out robo race
huh
so when i went to the electric e thing
formula
formula e electric uh
i saw them get in like an accident but
nothing really exploded because it's
electric
so cool remember yeah okay i don't know
if there's explosions in uh gas powered
cars all the time either sometimes
no that kind of crash would have caused
an explosion sometimes
i know i know my cars um okay okay so
bart is insane
so new york entered phase four nobody is
entirely clear what that means to be
honest
but now the government's shutting down
bars
taking liquor licenses like all this
stuff and i
like what andrew riggy the executive
director of nyc's hospitality alliance
said
he said the majority of restaurants and
bars are trying to do the right thing
but they need clarity and they're
confused with the ever-changing guidance
and requirements
like you can't punish businesses that
are trying to do the right thing but
when you change
things on a daily basis like how do you
are you supposed to know what's
happening you know what i think should
happen
what small business entrepreneurs would
say hey government you
suck you're preventing me from making a
living
while you steve keep collecting your
paycheck from my tax dollars
i'm opening up my restaurant or bar and
if people want to come here they're
going to come here
if they don't want to come here they're
not going to come here if they're
worried about getting sick
then they're not going to come if
they're not worried about it then
they're going to show up
but you can't prevent me from making a
living they're taking your liquor
licenses and they're making that's fine
and then i'm going to sue you and we've
seen in other states it's gone all the
way to state supreme courts
where the entrepreneurs have prevailed
because it is against the constitution
to do this you are preventing somebody
from making a living
and you can say all you want about the
the um social guidelines but it's like
what the guy in georgia said
right the governor in georgia said the
mayor of atlanta
is banning face masks right or is uh is
mandating sorry not
banning mandating face mess it is law
that you have to wear a face mask
and the governor in georgia said no no
you can't do that that's
unconstitutional
i'm going to sue the city of atlanta and
prevent you from doing that
by the way in the same exact engagement
on television
he then said people please please please
wear your masks
please wear the mask so what he is
saying is it is unconstitutional to use
the government and law
to implement and force people to do
something that is not what freedom is
about
but that doesn't stop us from telling
those same people please do this
now if people don't listen then that's
people are idiots well can i tell you
about it you can't use the law to
implement like this
because it is unconstitutional can i
tell you about one pub
owner what he did yeah what'd he do i
would love to oh i know yeah so
so cuomo governor andrew cuomo of new
york said if you're not eating a meal
and you're just drinking and then it's
just an outdoor bar and people are
mingling and not isolated at tables
which
in and of itself makes zero sense but
he's basically saying if you're just
drinking you're considered a bar you're
not an outdoor or whatever
so one pub added to its menu a one
dollar cuomo chips
uh so that it's considered a food and
eatery so that
you can go and get yeah it's just i mean
people obviously are finding ways to get
out of this it's just ridiculous
again because it's stupid rules it's
stupid rules
and so just tell us what the rules are
and entrepreneurs will figure out
solutions
so if you're going to say oh you can
only open if you serve food but you can
if you're a bar
find that we'll serve food we'll serve
one dollar cuomo chips idiot
but what's the difference between a
restaurant and a bar there
is none this is all made up rules and
the virus
is exposing the shams of society and
they're starting with the incompetence
of our elected leaders it just sucks
that the government can literally go
shut your
bar down and make sure you do not reopen
it's unconstitutional it doesn't
suck it's literally against the law for
them to do that they're trying to do it
they've gotten in trouble
multiple times because for example there
was churches that came out and they sued
uh i can't remember what city or state
it was but they sued and they said wait
a second
you're allowing the congregation of
people outdoors
and indoors for protests but not for
church
you're discriminating on us based on
religion because you're saying
specifically because you're a church you
can't open up but you're allowing other
people to congregate
everything is everything is very
confusing and
so we have here you have to go back to
first principles and you have to say we
cannot mandate people to do these things
it's unconstitutional
but we need them to do it right i'm not
arguing that people shouldn't be wearing
masks they shouldn't do social
distancing they should be doing all that
but the way to get them to do it is
through influence
not through authority and the way that
you influence them is you
educate them influence not authority
it's something that like being in the
military you learn like
everything in the military's uh
authoritative leadership i'm in charge
of you
i have a higher rank you do what i say
and that's the rules but when you get
into the business world what you realize
is everything is influential leadership
right you have to inspire people and
influence them to do the things that you
want them to do
and so and the latter is probably more
effective of course it's more effective
but governors and state politicians and
local politicians are confused
they think that they control us they
don't realize they work for us
we put them there we pay their salaries
and so if you want us to do things
influence us explain to us reason with
us educate us
tell us why we need to do something so
do not try to force us to do it because
people are just going to throw their
middle finger
up and say no and if you're at home
arguing like okay but the idiots who
aren't putting their masks on and
whatever
like we have to tell them what to do and
the government has to because this is a
good thing for them
yes but it's also a slippery slope
because if they tell you this oh yeah
sure it's a good thing and then they
tell you something else and it's like oh
[ __ ]
now i have to listen and you don't want
to it's
it's a very easy yeah free slope into
something else other than democracy
well and again this isn't my personal
opinion like literally this has gone to
state
supreme courts and the supreme courts
have ruled sometimes unanimously saying
it's illegal it's against the
constitution for you to mandate the
shutdown of businesses
and so what i think is going to happen
is there's we're going to see case after
case after case after case
to the point where the most egregious
thing i've seen recently is somebody
tested positive for covid
they would they refused to sign a legal
document that said they would self
quarantine
and so instead a judge forced them to
put a
gps enabled ankle tracking bracelet on
wait why is the government tracking you
with a gps that's for criminals
that's ridiculous but i have a quick she
says it's ridiculous
what happens when a business sues the
government and wins do do the taxpayers
pay
who pays well in many cases they're not
looking for financial damages
uh at least in most these cases they're
just looking for tell me that it's
constitutional or unprotected so i could
open my business
right i would want all the money oh
trust me there's some people who are
definitely gonna ask for money
for sure but i i don't know exactly like
what they're looking for what are the
damages how do you prove the damages
what's virus related versus government
related all that
flying ants i'm out i'm out because 2020
isn't weird enough
a swarm of flying ants stretched for
miles over the uk
and it literally looked like rain on the
weather radar
these are ants this is not rain um
so yeah look at that yeah i ain't
playing with this game uh i'm out i'll
see y'all later first of all who knew
that ants could fly that blue thing
right there is what they're saying are
flying ants
i ain't messing with ants i ain't
messing with flying ants i ain't messing
with the uk right now if they got flying
in
so anyone in the uk sorry but no way
yeah so the insects were you ever gotten
bit by like red ant like like the really
the ones that like uh that sting you and
stuff one time
i stepped in one in the woods i wasn't
playing man
i would have done anything to get them
away from me those guys are
they they're vicious so if they could
fly
i'm out did you see my did you see that
i didn't see the joke let's go okay so
i have two jokes today because
yesterday's got cut off because we had
technical issues so i'm gonna re-say it
but he already knows the answer
what did the big flower say to the
little flower
i don't know yes you do i was just
giving you a softball
hi bud
what's your next joke wait wait you got
25 seconds or i'm shutting off the
computer the other day he called me
buddy
why do bees have sticky hair because
they've been
buzzing around because they use
honeycombs these are getting worse
we're gonna we're gonna have an
intervention men and women
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
these jokes suck
submit your best joke in the comments so
i can surprise them with something
real good i'm just going to read them in
the comments don't read them in the
comments
all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today while while she's trying to
get rich that's
just trying to get our lunch money right
stop letting the government print money
and tell you what to do educate yourself
see
can i leave bang bang hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of lunch money as
much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends